منطقه الجوف في شمال السعوديه تضم حصولا
وقلاعا نتاريه تعود الى مراحل زمنيه
مختلفه منها قلعه زعبل التي يعود بناءها
الى الفتره النبطيه الممتده من القرن
الاول قبل الميلاد في شمال مدينه سكاكا
القلعه التاريخيه يجري في محيطها حراك من
التطوير من خلال اعمال الترميم والانشاءات
التي تتكامل مع طابع العمراني والاثري
للقلعه وذلك لتعزيز وصول السياح والزوار
كونها تعد من المعالم التاريخيه والسياحيه
المهمه في المنطقه
من قناه زعبل او زعبل في منطقه الجوف في
شمال السعوديه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
عبد الواحد عبد الحميد هيكل عبد الواحد
عبد الواحد اولا الاسمين صح ولا واحد منهم
الصح ربما والامر الثاني خلينا نتعرف اكثر
على هذه القلعه معك
اهلا بك خالد نعم طبعا باللهجه نقول زعبل
هي الاكثر يعني انتشارا بين سكان المحليين
نحن هنا في هذه القلعه اسفل القلعه تحديدا
حيث هناك العديد من البيوت التاريخيه
والاثريه نحاول ان نريكم القلعه في الاعلى
هي قلعه شاهقه جدا اسفلها يوجد العديد من
البيوت والمنازل التاريخيه التي يتم فيها
طبعا تم فيها ترميم سابقا في هذه البيوت
بالنسبه للقلعه هناك طبعا كما تعلم اكثر
من 3000 سنه تقريبا عمر هذه القلعه
فيما يتعلق بتفاصيل هذه القلعه نود ان
نتعرف اكثر من خلال لقائنا بالاستاذ نايف
اللحيد وهو مهتم بتاريخ قلعه بل اهلا
وسهلا بك استاذ نايف نريد ان نعرف اولا
تفاصيل هذه القلعه مما تتكون طبعا القلعه
هي مبنيه على يعني على تقريبا على طول 50
متر وهي تتكون من الصخر الرملي وبها شيء
من الطين
يسوي فيها في الاعلى على اربع ابراج تتولى
المراقبه وتكمن اهميه القلعه قلعه زعبل في
ذلك الوقت وفي تلك الحقبه تحديدا بانها
طال عمرك مسؤوله عن حمايه الحي وحمايه
مدينه سكاكا والاشراف على الطرق التجاريه
في ذلك الوقت وايضا الحمايه فكان صمودها
يعني صمود الحي وصمود المدينه وسقوطها في
ذاك الوقت يعني سقوط مدينه سكاكا فالقلعه
تكون اهميتها بكونها قلعه حربيه حصينه
مسؤوله عن حمايه المدينه والحج طيب
بالنسبه طبعا
المواد اللي تم صناعه من هذه القلعه نعرف
ان القلعه تم ترميمها تقريبا في اخر 200
سنه او قبل 300 سنه تقريبا الرممه القلعه
على وقت القرش حقيقه وكان الهدف من
الترميم هو اعاده دفاعاتها وتحصينها ايضا
الابراج تم كان طولها قصير ورفعت الى خمس
امتار تقريبا
لاعاده ترميمها من جديد وتحصينها بالنسبه
لهذا المكان اللي نحن متواجدين فيه الحين
قصر المسقوف وش قصته هذا طال عمرك المسقوف
كان يجتمعون فيه في وقت الازمات وتحديدا
المشاكل تمر في تلك الحقبه في المنطقه كان
يتناول فيه المواضيع السياسيه في ذلك
الوقت وطرق علاجها وحلها والتعاون فيما
بينهم طيب اخيرا استاذ نايف يعني نعرف ان
هذا المكان يعد يعني احد رموز منطقه الجوف
وطبعا
حتى الزوار والسياح ياتون باستمرار الى
هذه المناطق لزياره المساكن التاريخيه
والمنازل اسفل القلعه طبعا هي يعني تعتبر
صراحه متنفس للجميع كونها يعني مكان
تاريخي طلع يعني يعبر عن اصاله المنطقه
وعرقتها وتاريخها بقلعتها الشامخه وبيوتها
التي تمثل وتحاكي البيوت الموجوده في
الجزيره العربيه
والناس يستمتعون حقيقه بالطلوع الى اعلى
القلعه والاطلال على مدينه سكاكا الحي
ويعني يتفرجون عليه طب تاريخيا هذه
المناطق الاسفل القلعه كانت يعني حتى فيها
ربما البساتين وكانت مناطق الزراعيه نعرف
المنطق الجوف تعد من كبريات المناطق اللي
يعني منتشره فيها الزراعه
لخصوبه الارض الزراعيه في المنطقه طبعا
الاقتصاد في تلك الفتره وفي تلك الحقبه
تحديدا يعتمد على الزراعه وتحديد الزراعه
النخيل والنخله كما قال الرسول هيعمتنا
يعني وكان هي القوت التي يعتمد عليها
الاهالي القوه الغذائي ليعتمد عليها
الاهالي اللي هو التمر وكذلك يستفيدون من
حسبها بالسيوت المنازل وايضا حتى
الحيوانات حيوانات وبسيطه كانت تتغذى على
العسب ويسميه العسب حنا جريد النخل
فالنخله هي اقتصاد المنطقه في ذلك الوقت
شكرا جزيلا الاستاذ نايف الحيد على كل هذه
التفاصيل اللي زودنا فيها من اسفل قلعه
زعبل كما تشاهدون البيوت التاريخيه
العديده والمتنوعه اسفل هذه القلعه يزورها
الناس والزوار والسكان وحتى السياح
باستمرار
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من قناه في منطقه الجوف
في شمال السعوديه مراسل العربيه عبد
الواحد الحميد